Wow so thanks so much it's really it's
really a pleasure to be here I always uh
for tips I think there's one bond
oh it's it's on auto okay so let's try
to go back yes it's really a pleasure to
be here you know every time I come here
I feel like I learned so much I'm really
honored to be here because I'm probably
the worst our programmer in the entire
room you know I thought about what would
be useful for people in this room and I
wanted to present something so I want to
present something about what would be
useful for me so I thought about the
people who maybe work at organizations
in this area and I thought about back
when I was doing my PhD and I worked for
the World Bank here I thought about you
know what we were trying to do with the
World Bank and I wanted to translate
some of the things that we learned there
but I also wanted to tell about some of
my research so you know you can think
about this as how did art started this
is a very like sexy title I wanted to
get you in the room but really I'm just
gonna tell you a bit about my research
and also give you some tips on doing
machine learning projects that can scale
within an organization and just by way
of introduction I'm an assistant
professor of management science and
economics at Chapman University if
you've seen the TV show The OC
that is like not too far from like the
student population that we have there
and I you know I feel like so so I
always want to talk at my university
because it has a really great reputation
on the west coast so we get a choice of
California undergrads but you know these
are kids coming in off of Lake with
surfboards and skateboards and I can say
that we've had explosive growth with an
interest in machine learning
so I teach machine learning courses to
undergrads and MBAs and we've had nearly
a hard percent year-over-year growth so
now we teach four sections a semester of
machine learning we're opening up an
expanding kind of every business schools
doing this like trying to expand into
more analytics classes so it's a great
place to be if you're interested you
know this is just a great time for fir
machine learning so the thing I want to
talk about is you know when you think
about machine learning you often think
about these companies on the left so you
think about Facebook Google these are
so-called digital native companies
so these are companies that kind of from
top down they pretty much have a machine
learning or a coding mindset and you
know you know there's a lot of
organizations here you know think about
the world bank think about the
Department of census think about the
Consumer Financial Protection Bureau
these are a lot of the organizations
that are represented maybe in this room
and you pretty much can't expect that
people top-down have a digital native
mindset right and yet we're often the
people in those rooms maybe we're the
guy or the girl who's trying to
implement these solutions and anyone
who's done they say these organizations
realize how tough this is like
incredibly difficult and yet if you
think of the mission statement for these
organizations like we if we can
implement some of the machine learning
solutions at these organizations just
incredibly powerful and I would say that
the the low-hanging fruit for what is
possible it's much greater here than it
is over there no-knock if you happen to
work over here you probably make more
money if you work over here like a lot
of the people over here you know this is
where I think there's a lot of impact
that's still left to be made so okay so
but a lot of the conflict comes from
this aspect which is that like you know
who within an org chart it actually
understands machine learning right so
you pretty much maybe if you work in
like marketing or R&D you understand are
like how about you know to get any
project that's gonna scale you're gonna
have to like somehow communicate what
you're doing up to up the hierarchy and
so you know do the rest of the people
understand are do they understand
machine learning and how about the
people above them really like there's
this like no way that is happening
and yet the problem is the problem is
that you eventually need to like your
what your what thing you're doing that
transformative project which everyone in
this room has capabilities of making
some transformative project you
eventually need to make this its way
upwards and so I the the the advice I
want to give here me before I talk about
my research I want to talk about how you
scale that thing upwards within an
organization and you know there's a lot
of like constraints to an organization
for implementing these things and so
kind of the first piece of advice I want
to give you is you need to be able to
explain how your model works in language
not just how you understand it or how
your boss understands it but how your
boss's boss understands it so you can't
just you can't just throw it on
buzzwords you can't just say things like
CNN rnns
do we even understand what these mean
but you have to be able to explain them
in ways that your that that you know
they often say like you know the
grandmother tests like like explain this
two ways that your grandmother would
understand something and I think that's
a little patronizing but no think about
this it's not just about like not using
acronyms it's also about any culture has
its own way of doing things and as the
own way of explaining things and you
have to find a way to kind of bridge in
that machine learning topic and you have
to explain that using their own own
language so so find out like how they
communicate within an organization find
out how you can explain that machine
learning model and then communicate with
those two and I think that's really hard
because then you have to understand
actually what you're doing right you
have to understand it on so many levels
on mathematical level of programming
level and also kind of an intuitive
level and that's why you know I'm gonna
give a shout out to business school
students who learn machine learning
because that's one of the things we
focus on like from the get-go it's not
just about do you understand this
mathematically do you understand how to
program it but it's really like how do
you communicate within a team so maybe
hire some people from who have a
Business School background so another
thing so let's say like your able
communicate you got this great memo
report there might be another constraint
here it's like if you think about it
like how do these people really get to
the top right
and okay so let's say you're coming in
and you're like the new you got all the
new cool tools right so you're coming in
there you're all checked out but think
about your boss like your boss your boss
came in they're using the old mood cool
right so maybe your boss learned sass I
mean think about this like your boss
Rose rose network chart about what was
popular maybe 10 or 20 years ago so
maybe maybe your boss was like was the
best sass program in there and they you
rose to the top and I'm not so even if
your boss is interested in learning new
things like there's this natural
conflict where it's something's trying
to take food off your plate you're just
going to resist that kind of change it's
a natural human instinct and so the best
quote that I have for this I think is by
Upton Sinclair so it's difficult to get
a man to understand something when his
salary depends on is not understanding
it all right like especially at these
organizations that are so risk-averse
that it's just it's really hard to get
somebody especially your boss when it's
said hey we're gonna do this new thing
it does this other thing much better
than your old method that's gonna make
you obsolete like we're here we're here
to disrupt you like that's that's a
video to have a very very cautious
approach with that and kind of like
that's why I think like these type of
meetups where you're explaining the
people of different backgrounds that
helps it out because it's not like it's
not like an exclusive thing it's like
we're inclusive we're all going to learn
this process together but I think it's
naturally how most people learn okay so
so tip 2 I think the way that you
actually motivate this is you say you
know show the current methods and show
where they break like explain them so
here's what's lacking with the current
methods like I'm kind of a methods
person like I I think like this is a
really cool method we're gonna employ
this it's gonna be really fun but if
you're the type who you know got famous
or gotten renowned on the old methods
you're just gonna be naturally resistant
to the new stuff and there's a bit of
like a generational gradient within an
organization about who's willing to
implement new stuff so the way that you
do this is just just explain why the
current methods are not working
and so alright let's try that back
alright so so in my own work I often
work with satellite images and I try to
use these to fill in what are called
data gaps so data gaps are where we just
don't know enough information about
certain areas so my dissertation work I
took satellite images and I use computer
vision technologies a lot of the stuff
that like we saw earlier with hot dog
not hot dog I was using pretty much the
same models except I was extracting out
buildings not necessarily hot dogs I was
using to show how those can be correlate
with things like poverty and why that's
so important is because this is how most
surveys are gathered so we have to go to
somebody's house we have to interview
them for a series of hours and this is
incredibly labor-intensive incredibly
expensive and so the way that I showed
at the World Bank that this was broken
or at least I didn't I kind of like
highlighted this result which is that 57
countries have zero or only one poverty
estimate between 2002 and 2011 and so
you know my boss or my boss's boss they
got renowned on the basis of being the
best survey methodologist and that works
well in some cases but clearly there's a
gap and so the way in which way in which
that gap exists that's that invites some
new methodologies and some new new
possibilities all right so another tip
here is maybe I need to be honest about
the limitations of your method so you
want to show where your method does you
want to show where your method does well
and it's you know like don't be honest
about these things because in the real
world things are never quite as simple
as there are in your desktop so so I
like to show you know we're just gonna
keep watching ok so so I you know I
showed that these satellite imageries
they can be useful for predicting
poverty but I was very cautious about
what it what are the explanatory power
and it so it turns out that we can
explain somewhere between about 0.4 and
0.7 of predicted poverty using satellite
images now that's really good if you
have no poverty estimates for say the
last like 15 or 20 years but it's
obviously not going to replace
good survey so you know we're very
cautious like understand where these new
technologies can be useful and where
they where they're not necessarily going
to be useful all right but you really
don't want to you know you want to show
the upside potential you'll want to
undersell your own work like it's not
the case that you want to say like look
look like like this stuff is only going
to work in certain situations so if you
want to say like what is the potential
of the stuff if it really scales right
like that's the incredible thing about
these organizations that they're so big
that we they can like start implementing
things at scale and once they do like
then you have a lot of possibilities and
so you need to show that possibility so
that that person high in the org chart
says like ah if I'm the person who grabs
a hold of this then I'm gonna get
renowned for this right right so you're
gonna like spark their imagination about
this so one thing I always like to show
and these this is something I'm
experimenting worth of my own work is
using these they have these like micro
satellites by companies like planet and
so they're about the size of a breadbox
they cost about $30,000 and so right now
Planet has more satellites in orbit than
any other organization and in fact they
have somewhere like two hundred or 200
satellites that are constantly scanning
the Earth's globe so we have daily
satellite images of all the Earth's land
surface some of you were not in your
head because you know about this data so
you know think about like how but you
know maybe maybe right now like this is
just like a small child but like think
imagine what happens in the smoke when
this small child grows up so always try
to like you know show what is what are
the capabilities at this so this is this
is a we've done an image classification
over land use and so this is an image of
every road in Mexico trained off of that
planet imagery so if you wanted to you
could capture water every Road in Mexico
at the daily rate so you can see like
expansion of roads expansion you know at
the monthly or some arbitrary frequency
see just kind of leaks you know this is
sexy you got to sell it so okay so so
Jared said that he wanted me to do
something technical he's like you can't
just come up here to a bunch of beans
and the problem is that like as a
researcher you're you know these things
take a long time and so like it was only
six months since my
talk so I'm gonna talk about the things
that I've done since and so shifting
gears a bit I'm gonna talk about some
research where we're trying to answer
the question do Internet enabled mobile
phones increase traffic accidents I'll
let you think about you in your own
lives about whether it's like a danger
for you for helping you out and this is
joint work of Matt and Bri Lang at UC
Riverside and so they're working paper
we just released is car accidents and 3G
coverage new evidence using cell phone
towers and you can kind of think about
how we're weaving in those principles
even though we're like now we're like
academics in the wild doing whatever we
want like you can think about how this
could be something that you could
implement and maybe the Department of
Transportation there's nothing here that
we're doing that is different then you
couldn't do on your own so so think
about those principles and how we're how
are we even goes in alright so ok so
we're gonna look at the growth of 3G
technology only within California we're
looking at the growth of cell towers as
well as the growth of just Internet
enabled like at the road level so our
unit of observation is gonna be a road
and we're gonna measure between 2001 and
2016 when did that get access to we're
gonna measure all the cellular towers
the nice feature is that the government
makes any cell tower register so we have
all this rich data on cell towers and so
we're just gonna measure and this is
this is the growth at the road level
which roads get access to to 3G coverage
and this is like this is a great event
study right like if every road is
getting access to at different times you
can think that's exhaust a bunch of
other stuff then we can measure the
impact in here so here's the problem and
this is where machine learning is gonna
come here is that we only measure 3G
coverage at one time period in 2000 and
we know all this other rich data about
the closest tower characteristics for
these roads between the entire sample
and the solution here is that we're
gonna fill in the data gap so we're
gonna build a random forest or a machine
learning model to predict 3d coverage
through this time period so that's going
to tell us we're gonna get predicted
coverage for 3G axes at the road level
and we're gonna do this based on like a
rich rich dataset on Tower
characteristics like tower elevation
tower height kind of the elevation
around the area when the tower was built
and of course we're gonna do this in
carrot because carrots a great package
for using this stuff
shout out to carrot shout out to max
okay alright so let's see how this house
I'll walk you through how we do this
okay alright so the first thing we want
to do is once we've loaded our data we
certainly want to cross validate select
our parameters and the carrot has really
nice like sampling features so this is
where we're cross bounding over m try so
that's a number of variables the sample
at every split it looks like five is the
optimal for all these different models
these three different models are
different assumptions about the
introduction so when was actually three
G axis introduced because we don't know
that starting date we have some ideas
about reports about when 3G technology
was introduced but it's kind of like
staggered introduction so we either
assume that was introduced in 2003 2004
or 2005 we pretty much know by 2006
there's 3G access and you know the 3G
acts is the thing that's really gonna
distract you that's a thing like you
know having Facebook all these other
things that are gonna distract you while
you're driving
and it looks like the the 2005
Assumption of introduction of 3G axis is
the thing that really um that that does
the best so all right so another thing
first that that is but that suggests
that we should use 2005 is the
introduction of 3G access is that if we
plot like the in red we see the random
forest prediction for the fraction of
roads that have access to 3G and then we
see the like the fraction of like like
mobile broadband subscribers per hundred
inhabitants we see that these two things
like match each other really well so
this red is the prediction we get from
the random forest this blue is actual
data they match pretty well so we know
that our predictive American models
doing something real here
all right so now we're gonna do some
model calibration this is something I
always like to do with any model that I
do what we're going to do is we're going
to take all those predicted
probabilities that we have so now we
have just from 0 to 1 for every road
what's the probability that this road
has 3G access at a time period we're
going to bunch up we're gonna do bins of
those predicted probabilities so the
ones between zero and point one point
one and point two and a so called well
calibrated model is one in which if we
predict it to have 10% probability of
having a lik 3G or some event we should
observe that you know one out of 10 of
those actually has the event and so what
we want is we want like these dots to
line up perfectly on the 45 degree line
and ok so it's not perfect so we're kind
of like under calibrated initially and
then we're over calibrated but this is
about as good as like a models I've ever
built I don't know this looks ok it
doesn't look it doesn't look like too
bad yeah it kind of goes up sinusoidal I
know mine tend to look like that but it
doesn't look like totally wack right
that's also a technical term now of
course we don't do some out-of-sample
accuracy plots so this is in the test
sample like when you first do an RFC
plot like this you're like well I
obviously overfit something but but this
is in the test set so I don't know
what's happening this is better than any
model I've ever built I don't know
what's going on maybe there was some
type of information leak between the
test and training set right it looks
like that but it's not I promise you
know I just admit I don't know it's a
really it's maybe it's a very easy
prediction problem because the area
under the curve is is super high but
when you look at something like this
you're like wow this is really over fit
but but it's not this isn't the test set
so so good on me not bad thanks Obama
thanks Obama alright so that's all the
machine learning stuff we're gonna embed
this machine learning technology within
an event study and the event study is
gonna measure what is the probability of
an accident right when we get access to
a to 3G technology on that road we're
gonna do a fixed effect plus on model
Poisson model we're gonna use that as
opposed to regression because it's a
count data problem you can't have
fractions of accidents you can't have
negative accidents and so we're gonna
estimate this model the coefficient of
interest here is this theta that's just
gonna measure what happens before and
what happens after the timing of the
introduction of 3G like so once this
road gets access we're gonna line up all
the roads right when they get access to
3G and figure out what happens before
and what happens after and you might say
that some roads just how our more
dangerous so we're gonna control for the
average road traffic and we're actually
gonna have road fixed effects so that if
one road is just like know also janky or
like has some sort of like just just has
like a higher probability of accidents
we're gonna control for that and we're
going to control time fixed effects so
maybe in December there's more accidents
for whatever reason all right so let's
look so let's see whether actually like
getting access to mobile enabled cell
phones cause more accidents the suspense
okay so we're plotting the probability
of an accident on the y axis and then on
the x-axis we're prodding the years
relative to that change whether you
whether you get 3g axis or not and so it
looks at you know pretty much a you know
two years after getting access to 3g
remember this 3g is predicted looks like
we have an increase in probability of
accidents and then three or four years
out we get a much greater increase in
probability of accidents
and we can do this heterogeneous based
on the age of the driver because we
actually know a lot of information on
accidents so it looks like not
surprisingly younger drivers are more
susceptible to looking at their phones
when they should be driving
so this first plot up here to left this
is for accidents for people 29 and
younger see like much in greater
increase in probability of accident and
but pretty much you know the people
between 30 and 40 and 50 and 64 also are
tempted by using their cell phones so
they also have like a higher propensity
of getting in traffic accidents
following this road has in having 3G
access it's only the people who are 65
and older that have no no temptation
whatsoever
people are not tempted by looking at
their phones so so sorry sorry mom and
dad you guys are rather in bad luck all
right so to conclude we see that
accident rates increased by 1.1 percent
when a row gets access to 3G coverage
and Internet this is so if you look at
this in aggregate it looks like internet
connected mobile phones cause over 3,000
accidents in California it's not crazy
to me and I think one thing that's
really cool is this is just further
evidence that you can embed machine
learning predictions within a causal
model right people often say that oh
machine learning it's only for
prediction that's all you can do but no
no this is causal we've just embed it
within a causal model here okay all
right so comet suggestions please please
email me I'm always happy to talk about
this if you want to sponsor my research
wanna or you want to make me aware of
any grants I would love to talk to you
and like I said we're always expanding
in you know the number of classes that
we're offering so if you happen to be in
the Southern California area and you
want to teach a class like like I handle
a lot of the curriculum there so I'd
love to talk to you about that so I know
we're all we're always tiring like
full-time non-tenure-track people so if
you want to talk about teaching class or
we would love to have you okay all right
thanks
you